ils ne font pas tous le même métier mais
ils partagent la même passion le vélo
depuis le début du confinement
l'association les boîtes à vélo s'est
donné pour objectif d'aider commerçants
et artisans à maintenir leur activité
loin de leur profession exercée dans
leur vie quotidienne
ils se sont reconvertis en livreur le
temps du confinement
merci le service démarre
depuis quelques quelques semaines et on
a effectivement de plus en plus de
demandes de clients qui souhaitent être
livrés à domicile puisque les
restaurants sans tarder après avoir agi
de manière bénévole dans un premier
temps l'association propose désormais
une formule payante avec des tarifs
abordables
depuis le 17 mars les commandes
explosent notamment celles liées à la
restauration la livraison à domicile a
été la bouée de sauvetage des
restaurateurs rester en activité pendant
le confinement ou que c'est très
intéressant surtout sur un trafic de
livraison ça permet de garder le contact
avec nos clients aussi de les rassurer
pour ce qui est finalement un peu porte
se rendre en boutique et de niang wa
possibilité effectivement va des
circuits les plus rapidement de
stationner plus facilement
c'est un moyen de locomotion qui est non
polluant aujourd'hui et qui aux heures
de pointe finalement va beaucoup plus
vite que la voiture et qui permet de la
livraison de proximité beaucoup plus
facilement le vélo s'est révélé être un
excellent moyen de livraison rapide
économique et non polluant des atouts
qui pourrait être pérennisée après la
pandémie et qui donnerait au vélo une
place prioritaire dans le transport
urbain de proximité
c'est le pari de caroline fondatrice de
la branche lyonnaise des boîtes à vélo
parce qu'ils aient une ouverture ça va
donner aux artisans les commerçants la
possibilité d'envisager un nouveau
business avec la livraison à la porte
des clients particuliers parce qu'on
fait on se rend bien compte que le vélo
est d'atlanta de plus en plus importante
finalement c'est un révélateur
depuis sa création en 2015 à nantes les
boîtes à vélo se sont pérennisés un peu
partout en france
au point de fonder la première
fédération des travailleurs à vélo